when you get to winning
for me it's come down to maxing out and
what maxing out means is you do one more
at least than you think you're capable
of so when you're done whatever you're
doing whether it's at the gym or phone
calls or meetings or in sports one more
shot one more throw one more swing of
the golf club or the baseball bat the
separator is for the winners they do one
more i'm addicted to one more and so i
want your mantra going forward to be one
more what does that look like if we're
working out that means when we're in the
gym and we say i'm gonna do five sets of
ten i'm crazy like i'm a psycho because
i wanna win i wanna be somebody i wanna
separate i wanna compete
and the way i do that
isn't with my giftedness because i
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and i
think gifts are crap hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that's holding you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best belief
life and get some incredible motivation
from the one and only ed my left
enjoy
[Music]
i think for the most part gifted people
struggle in life because things come
easy them i like that things haven't
come easy for me in my life i like they
don't have natural talents in every area
and maybe you like that about you too
maybe you've looked at yourself all your
life and thought man i don't have that
natural beauty or that natural talent or
this gift for creativity or intellect or
humor i don't have any of those things
but what i got is i will outwork you and
so at the gym one of the things i focus
on they say it's 5 sets of 10. when i'm
at 10 i go one more bam 11. if i'm
running on the treadmill and it's a 45
minute run i never finish at 45. i
always go one more minute 46.
if i'm at the office and i'm supposed to
make 25 phone calls that day when i'm at
the end of the day i always do one more
if i've got meetings i always do one
more my mantra for three decades in
business has been one more why because
we get out of life what we think we
deserve and i'm the kind of guy that i
know when you do 45 minutes on the
treadmill and i do 46 i deserve to be
fitter i know that when i'm lifting
weights and i watch you do five sets of
ten and every single time i do one more
when it's a set of five i do six when
it's a set of eight i do nine when it's
45 on the treadmill i do 46. when it's
supposed to be 20 phone calls i make 21.
when it's supposed to be an eight hour
workday i work nine whatever it is i
always do one more and what that does is
it makes me eventually think i'm doing
things other people aren't willing to do
so i should get things other people
aren't going to get most of you lose
control of your life in the first five
minutes after you wake up i talk about
it in my book and you begin to respond
all day long the first thing is this
the hardest thing you will do and the
thing that will change your life almost
with the greatest impact is to not check
your phone for the first 30 minutes you
wake up in the morning i'm telling you
that it might be the biggest game
changer it is the biggest game changer
for me it was so difficult because so
what i did is i i moved it away from
where i sleep but i'm just going to say
to you all you think that's not a big
deal i got to check i'm telling you if
you could go 30 minutes if you could
start by going 10 minutes to begin your
day something where you do not check
that sucker and react and then what you
say about the gratitude thing that's
profound for me and it's a breakthrough
for me when you said it i'm always kind
of like what are the big things i'm
great i'm grateful for god i'm grateful
for my kids you reduce it down to just
something what's the smallest thing you
can be grateful for right i love that
because there's always a small thing
you'd be grateful for you know i'm glad
i'm grateful my i clipped my toenails
yesterday whatever it is right there's
something so i just want to validate how
powerful i think both those simple tools
the simplest things make the biggest
impacts in our lives i want to remind
you of something you are one decision
away from changing your life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact one new action
one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place so what's the decision you already
know i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave i don't know what it
is but i know there's a decision that
you need to make to take you to the next
level just like i know that's true for
me because decisions shape our destiny
when they're backed up by some massive
ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially their relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those you that are achieving one of
the reasons the achievement has slowed
down is you've allowed yourself to feel
less desperate
when you were broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship and you were desperate
to get her to love you or desperate to
get him to love you you took massive big
action how many of you are moms in the
room raise your hand you mobs if you
woke up tomorrow morning and your baby
wasn't in their bed would you be
desperate right away yes or no
big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take massive
action you searched the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you
you wouldn't would you have to have the
perfect plan to go find your baby that's
missing you wouldn't need any of that
because you were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all zen and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and i
want you to get desperate to make that
decision
why because our obsessions become our
possessions which you obsess about most
regularly you will eventually possess in
your life the challenge for most people
sisters and brothers is that we obsess
on the things we're fearful of what we
don't have what we're worried about and
then we end up possessing those things
over and over again rather than
programming ourselves to become obsessed
with what we want what our dreams are
what we believe we deserve when we
become obsessed about those things long
term we end up possessing those things
can i get an amen for that yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives because
those things happen
naturally without thought the external
results of our life in order to replace
ourselves with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones
it's unnatural to be the same person you
are right now next year for all of you
in here the 35 year old you should be
gone next year forever and there should
be a brand new better 36 year old you 20
year olds there should be a better 21
year old next year you should constantly
be replacing yourself just like your
bones do just like your lungs do just
like your cells do it's natural to be
replacing ourselves but we're around
people who aren't so we think it's
natural not to some people deceive
themselves into thinking they're further
ahead than they are right yeah
constantly i'm you know they always want
to tell you how well they're doing and
they're sort of deceiving themselves and
that deception leads to lack of activity
drive desire blah blah you and i do the
reverse yeah i deceive myself i'm
further behind than i am i know you do
this too because we've talked about it
holy i love deceiving myself i love
deceiving our company i love being i
love deceiving the team because i want
us to feel like we got malcolm x has
this great quote he says that which you
do not hate you will eventually tolerate
i'm a big believer and i i gotta almost
despise where i am right now and i do so
i'm i'm kind of the king of deception
with myself if you're stuck
you're stuck in a story
that's where you're stuck there's a
story you're telling yourself that
doesn't serve you anymore
and you have to evaluate what that story
is i'm serious right now if you say ed
i'm kind of stuck where i am well what
you need to do is you need to alter your
associations you need to do something in
a short window of time no question about
it you definitely need to evaluate what
is no longer needed and evaluate the
story you're telling yourself there's
all kinds of stories we tell ourselves
that don't serve us anymore this is
critical maybe it's a story about your
past a story about your parents a story
about a previous relationship a story
about a success you used to have you
keep talking about that doesn't serve
you to get to the next level
if i can be real with you whatever
you've achieved up to this point that
story you keep talking about every
second you spend in that old story about
what you've achieved your degree
some business you had one thing you were
real successful at in the past every
time you live in that story you're
stripping time and focus from the news
story what's the new story you're
telling yourself you can't have a new
identity without a new story
what's the old story you keep for being
maybe it's not a success maybe it's a
failure that you've had it was a
business setback it was the market
turned it was the economy it was someone
who did you wrong a relationship that
let you down a business partner who
wasn't consistent a failure you've had a
poor decision you made
a mistake you made
in your life and you're repeating this
story to yourself simultaneously trying
to create a new identity you can't take
that old story into the new identity you
got to be able to have a big enough
dream that the visions and the dreams of
the people you're going to enroll into
your organization they're going to
become a part of your team or your
company
their dreams and their visions can fit
inside this big one you've got that's
what makes you magnetic that's what
makes you compelling that's what
attracts people to you
so anything art used to say any church
boy scout troop football team you show
me something that's when it's run by a
leader and leaders have a vision where
there is no vision people perish where
there's no vision your business perishes
when there's no dream whatever endeavor
it is you're involved in will eventually
perish but if the dream's alive the
dream is big enough you can accomplish
anything because you'll overcome the
adversity the tough times the difficult
times that the people who ultimately
lose won't overcome really winning in
business is more about staying power
more about relentlessness more about
tenacity more about vision more about
dreams than it's ever about skill you
show me someone with enough vision a big
enough dream i'll show you somebody who
will eventually acquire the skills the
talents or the other people necessary to
make that huge dream happen but i've
seen all kinds of talented people all
kinds of skilled people
that succumb to adversity you have an
acceptance that problems and challenges
are going to exist isn't it probably
important that you learn to enjoy the
process of overcoming them and solving
them i think all the time and how can i
enjoy this i think man what are all the
great things that are going to happen
when this is solved whose lives are
going to be better when this is solved
how much better is my body my fitness my
faith my family my life other people's
lives when this problem is solved
depending on what the problem and
challenge is and that helps me enjoy the
process i also remind myself this
problem is helping me grow it's it's in
existence because i'm making progress in
my life so all these things fit a
meaning that help us make the best
decisions possible you and i watched
every successful person that we know
everyone gets hammered man everyone gets
knocked down
you miss a close someone changes their
mind yeah you get rejected in interview
you you you you lose your baseball card
whatever the hell it is it's not whether
you're getting knocked down it's not
even whether you get up everybody
eventually gets up everybody gets up
yeah it's the time you're on your ass
it's the time you stay on the mat so
what happened was my dream got squashed
instead of laying around for six or
eight months i was up immediately like
that day off the mat now my eyes are
open your eyes are closed when you're on
the mat so the longer you stay on the
mat just because you've been defeated
you've now become blinded as you said
and it's prevented from getting any
other opportunity or blessings in your
life so the key is getting your butt up
like literally getting up and opening
your eyes again and chasing again you're
gonna get up so you might as well do it
now i'm no better than you same god that
made you made me i don't love my kids
more than you love your kids
if you make come with these adjustments
man you could change your life
you could change your family forever
it's not casual
your family treats that's so you know
something you meet somebody wealthy
their family at one point was not
wealthy
and then the one shows up
the one
one person changes a family tree forever
in my family i'm the one
and it was because i wanted it or i
hoped for it
right
hey
i fought for it
i fight for the interest give me the
info tell me what to tweak
i like that evangelist thing man that
stuff about influence is awesome i
thought he was smarter than me turns out
he's dumber than me
i want to win i want to fight for my
family i want my mom and dad proud of me
i want my kids proud of me
i want me proud of me i want to look in
the mirror and be happy with the man i
look back at dreams compound you'll
start with certain dreams that you think
is the first dream you've got and when
you achieve that it's like a muscle that
gets bigger and you begin to become
almost like a train maker
you almost become a dream maker where
you begin to achieve one dream and then
it also becomes this belief you have
this faith you have that other dreams
can happen you wake up one day and
you've achieved dreams and visions and
memories in your life that you never
even initially even compelled never even
thought were possible
and now you never even conceived of them
and now you're doing things you're
living in such a way that you couldn't
have even dreamed in the beginning but
the reason you got to the ultimate dream
the bigger than the dream is you could
dream dream
is because in the beginning you created
an end in mind you had a vision you had
a dream that was big enough to magnetize
people and it was big enough to get you
to stick through all the adversity
because there is adversity
there's difficult times in anything
but it's your ability to see past it to
the to the end in mind to the pot at the
end of the rainbow after the storm to
see that that gets you through the storm
that's the biggest thing people do
they're so obsessed with other people
that it kills them and they think about
what are they thinking about me what are
they going to think about me what are
they saying and then they measure
themselves against other people too and
i don't think i mean i've been around
you you're you're a powerhouse but
neither one of us are
yeah i think you're talking about
einstein at the break neither one of us
have a super crazy off the charts iq
yeah right i sure know you don't so i
can talk to you for enough i know for
sure you've done that a couple times
yeah
he's taking shots out it's obvious
they're watching they know they've seen
you yeah
no but the fact of the matter is you
don't get where you are
you didn't get where you are because of
some gifted i can't wait to meet your
wife though man you know no but it's a
fact both of us didn't get there because
of some unbelievable natural giftedness
we have that just produced success right
so i don't measure myself against other
people because they've got gifts that
are different than mine yeah number one
problem in the world today is people say
i'm going to delay my happiness until a
future time once i get that relationship
then i'll let myself be happy once i
have the house then i'll be happy once i
have the car then i'll be happy once i
have the promotion i'll be happy once i
have a certain amount of money then i'll
be happy the problem is you have to
bring you to all those places and people
think if i lose if i let myself enjoy my
life right now i might lose my edge the
athletes i coach think that all the time
nothing could be further from the truth
in fact if you don't enjoy the victories
as you go your brain doesn't produce any
dopamine and you actually lose the
desire to continue to perform there's a
direct correlation between celebrating
your wins and wanting to do more of them
i think you got to find a business
you're going to start and here's what i
did i played a game with myself and that
game was this if i hit my certain goals
in a given month i think you should go
touch your dreams i think you should
live in your dreams i think the more
familiar you become with your dream or
whatever it is you want the more you can
touch it feel it and be around it yeah
the more likely you can
get it the more likely you'll acquire it
and so one of the big things that i did
was i would set these goals up whether
it be an income goal or a production
goal this is when i was part-time as an
entrepreneur and i'd say if we hit x
we're going to go away for one night
and that one night would be to a nice
place it might be like the ritz carlton
laguna beach right where i would go or
the
resort in palm desert and i do one night
in my dream i'd spend the three or four
hundred bucks my wife would get a nice
massage taste of it and i'd go play golf
and guess who you run into those golf
courses yeah yeah you run into some rich
dudes and i'd run into those guys on the
golf course and i would get to know them
for that weekend that time so it wasn't
you you're touching possibilities you're
living in your dream the more you can
touch it if your dream is to feed a
million people spend one day a month
actually in those charities feeding
people the more you're comfortable in
your dreams so you don't wait until you
you're set to do it you get little you
never do you know this every little
thing you've acquired even even getting
elena you talked about how you chased
her for 13 months you got you got around
her a little bit in the meantime because
the more comfortable she could get with
hearing your voice messages are from you
the more likely she's going to get into
your because you belong in your dream
but you have to touch it regularly
before you get it if you land it all
back up i walk into cottage eight and
it's before school and there's ten boys
all eight nine and ten years old running
around getting ready for school and
right when i walked in they looked at me
all of them in the family room and kids
that come from abuse of any type have
different eyes than kids who don't and
in that minute my life changed because
these boys wanted someone to love them
believe in them
coach them tell them how to live their
life better and i started coaching
people and believing in people and
loving people and giving to people in
that moment involuntarily my whole life
changed in that instant for this reason
i fell in love with giving
i fell in love with being a giver
everything you want to do to get to the
next level listen to me i don't have a
business talk today if you could
identify how you could give more give
more of your love give more of your
belief give more of your time give more
of your effort give more of your energy
you will go to the next level if you're
not feeling great about yourself or
where your life is right now the pathway
out of that is giving it will always be
giving is everybody with me on that say
yes
i i promise you
i felt so good and i believe the pathway
you were born to do something great
because it's to give something something
big and something small it might be as
small as a prayer that you just whisper
for somebody in the room they never know
you gave them it's a hug it's i believe
in you it's time it's it's whatever it
is it's what can i give couple ironic
things about closing and selling that
you may not have ever been told before
but i'm gonna tell you
people don't have to believe what you're
saying
is that crazy
people do not have to believe what
you're saying in fact too many of you
spend too much time trying to get people
to believe what you're saying
and you come across like a beggar
because of it
you seem desperate who's ever trained
you to get people to believe what you're
saying
doesn't get influenced
there's a subtle difference that the
great ones know
and you've probably never been told this
before but i know it
and persuasion is not about getting
people to believe what you're saying you
ready
persuasion is about getting people to
believe
you believe what you're saying
that's a subtle difference brother
that's a subtle difference sister if you
start to think through i need to get
people to believe i believe this not to
get them to believe it people buy things
all the time they don't believe
people buy things all the time they
don't understand that's okay we want to
educate we want to train but they don't
have to believe everything you're saying
if they have to do that you're going to
look like you're begging all the time
they got to believe you believe it
that's a different intention the most
certain person always influences the set
less certain person when you're
exchanging with a recruit or a client
they're either going to close you or
you're going to close them
and that's certainty certainty is
influence and you can't transfer to me
something that you're not experiencing
for real you have to really believe it
you got to really be a crusader you got
to really understand it when you really
believe something you can transfer that
certainty to me everybody with me on
that say yes this is a huge deal it's a
huge deal that you need to begin to
understand
that persuasion is they believe you
believe what you're saying i love that
most people don't take anything
seriously i love that most people aren't
coachable i love that most people don't
do what i teach or that anybody teaches
i love that that's how certain people
win half y'all haven't written a damn
word down i've said if you were in my
team i'd slap the hell out of you
i don't say that disrespectfully i say
this as a [ __ ] who had a velcro car
i don't say that talking down to you i
say wake up
you want to win you want to be a
millionaire you got to quit being so
casual
you walk slow you talk slow you
implement things slow you talk a good
game like you're going to be somebody
like you're going to make hundreds of
thousands of dollars you can't even
write a note down
you're going to get your ass kicked in
business dude
business is a sport it's competitive you
got to get focused
and get in a hurry
around a dude like me we will smash your
organization we come to play we're for
real
what are you
cool
i've seen all kinds of cool guys my
whole career
cool guys go broke
cool guys have little flashes in the pan
they have a good two or three years
players who implement strategies that
get focused and intense
they win decades they win multiple
championships you win for two or three
years you know many guys i've known that
have made money for two three four years
that are ass broke now
you gotta win year after year after year
to be a player in business we often talk
and hear speeches in wfg myself included
tfa
about identity and belief and leadership
building and how we think and being
positive and hard work and all these
intangible things
but at the end of the day it's the
tangible things it's the real things
that make businesses grow or die
in our business it's the ability to get
somebody to produce a result or what i
call closing closing is a nice way of
saying
or a harsh way of saying i guess
getting people to do things that are in
their best interest persuading people to
say yes and in our business if you can't
persuade people to say yes you're going
to lose
in our business it's yes to the
opportunity and yes to our financial
products
and at the end of the day what our
business comes down to is
can you close can you get a check can
you get people to say yes to you
to buy a product from you or to buy our
business from you
and then from there it's your
proficiency level your ability to
transfer that skill of closing people
to other people
and if you can't do it you're going to
lose
it's the number one skill it's the
number two skill it's number five skill
it's the number 10 skill in our business
i don't care what list you have it's by
far the most important thing and it's
the most important thing multiplied by
10 times other things you could come up
with the ability to get people to say
yes the ability to give a presentation
at the end of it they say yes the
ability to overcome objections when
someone says the basic things in our
business i want to think about it it's
too much money i don't want to be a
salesperson i read something on the
internet i want to talk to my wife
is this network marketing whatever the
questions are the objections you get
your ability to overcome them and move
to yes if you can't do that you're going
to lose here if you can't train people
to do that you're going to lose here if
your meetings don't train people to do
that people will stop coming to those
meetings
we spend way too much time my
hallucination is you and your office
spend way too much time on motivating
inspiring speeches instead of teaching
instead of actually getting people to do
our craft to become professionals get
yourself to do it you think about it if
you drew a line in the sand you said
these are all the people in our
organization's history that have gotten
a check or have gotten to smd
and then on the other side are all the
people who didn't get to smd or have
never gotten a check
what do all the people have gotten to
check or let's just say got to smd which
is just a basic level in our company of
proficiency
have gotten to that level
what do they all have in common well not
a lot
some of them are smart some of them are
so smart some of them are
caucasian some of them are asian black
hispanic you name it
some of them are tall some of them are
short some of them are men some of them
are women some of them are immigrant
some were born in our country they don't
have a whole lot in common some are
married some are single some are old
some are young what do they have in
common
they can all close
they can all get a yes or at least at
one time in their career they developed
the ability to give a presentation at
the end of it somebody said yes they
knew the words they knew how to say they
knew what to say when someone says well
give me some time let me think about it
or is this too much money or you know i
read this or is this network marketing
or you know the basic stuff right
they're not mysteries there's only about
eight or ten things people say to us to
object there aren't eight hundred
there's eight or ten basic ones
and when you can overcome those things
and give a presentation you win we know
they can do this because we wouldn't
have sent them a check without their
ability to do it i'm positive they could
do it at one point because we sent them
a check all these other people over here
who didn't make it didn't get a check or
didn't get smd with all them in common
some are smart some aren't so smart some
are black some are white some are asian
some are hispanic
you get the point some are tall some are
short they gotta they got all that in
common too what do they all for sure
have in common they can't close they
can't get a check that's why we never
sent them one that's why they quit
that's why people quit on you be very
clear people quit on you or you will
quit based on your ability or inability
to close
when you can close you're going to do
our business and when you can close and
then you can teach people how to
persuade people which is closing
you're really going to build something
significant so i was just visiting about
this topic with my kids and i thought
you and i ought to visit about it too
because it applies so deeply to business
and that's the concept of belief and how
that impacts our performance in
everything
in our lives and i want you to think
about belief for a second see if you're
a good person and that's really where
this applies is to good people but good
people only let themselves in almost any
endeavor any activity good people only
take from it that which they believe
they deserve
now bad person they'll always take more
than they deserve because that's what
people without character do but good
people and i hope you consider yourself
a good person
they'll only take from something that
they think they deserve let me give you
an example let's say there was a pizza
here we were going to serve there's 12
people here there's 12 slices of pizza
well you know how you'd react and any
good person they'd either wait for
everybody else to get their piece or
they only take one slice because they
know that the other people there only
would have one left for them bad person
they just take any time they want to
wouldn't they so a good person will only
take from any scenario that which they
think they deserve that's a good thing
it's also a bad thing
because ultimately what it comes down to
in business is really this
when it comes to your business life or
becoming affluent saving money getting
financially independent you'll only take
from your life
and from your business
that which you think you deserve and so
really almost more important than
strategy is an internal identity it's an
internal belief that says i deserve this
i deserve to be happy i deserve to have
this dream come true i deserve to be
financially independent i deserve to be
in the top 10 in my business i deserve
to be number one or my team deserves to
my family deserves to and once you
believe you deserve something then
you've at least opened the door to walk
into the room of success but prior to
believing you deserve it you can do all
the work all the calls all the mechanics
that the other people do but if you
don't believe you deserve it you're
never going to even walk into the room
and sit at the table to have a chance to
get your piece
that the chair at the table the space at
the table is only reserved for those who
believe they deserve to be sitting there
i'm going to tell you right now either
you're going to control your time or
your time is going to control you either
you are going to dictate the terms of
your life or you're going to be somebody
who reacts and responds throughout their
life
this device right here can both speed up
time in your life or it can slow it down
it's not always a speed tool so one of
the tips that i've covered before but
not enough people implement that i
promise you is a quality of max
outperformers that relates to their time
is they control it they do not react and
respond they dictate the terms of their
life most of the time and that means
this when you wake up in the morning the
greatest thing you could do for yourself
is not touch or look at this device for
30 minutes to an hour after awakening so
that when you wake up you take control
of your time you control the time you
control the beginning of the day you get
clear you meditate you pray you stretch
you think you go through a gratitude
exercise you control the first 30
minutes of your day it sets a tone that
i'm in charge of my time not what enters
this
if the first thing you do is grab this
this now dictates the term of your day
this controls my day what hits this what
email what text what call hits this what
instagram post hit this this controls me
it controls my time but if you can stay
away from it for the first 30 minutes to
an hour you send a message to your brain
to yourself that you control time that
this day is on your terms and again you
stack up a day a week a month a year
five years of a lifetime of you
controlling and dictating the terms of
your life for just the first 30 minutes
to an hour every day i have a show where
i interview kind of top achievers and
you know athletes entertainers business
people and when i started the show i
thought it's gonna be fascinating to
find out what they all have in common is
it hard work brilliance charisma
and frankly it's on it's a skosh of
unhappiness because achievers even
people like yourself and this is people
that are that are out there like that
who should consider this we have this
thing where we're really never living up
to what we think we're capable of and
that's a good thing because it pulls us
to get better but it can also be a
formula for misery if you never just
decide you know a lot of achievers think
well if i enjoy this moment right now
i'm going to lose my drive i'm going to
lose my ambition so they cheat
themselves for all of the joy all of the
the juice that comes from winning and i
found if you give yourself that dopamine
hit when you achieve something you allow
yourself to enjoy it your brain wants to
do it again and again and again but if
you rob yourself of it that's when
burnout starts to happen because you're
not giving yourself any of the the
rewards for your hard work the coins
flip on each other all the time don't
they another form of distraction is just
doubt and doubt comes from the suffer it
comes from a loss it comes from fear it
comes from the sacrifice and so just
remember this you're supposed to suffer
and sacrifice so let me ask you a
question what are you willing to risk in
order to make your dream come true
nothing ventured nothing gained you're
going to take a risk maybe it's
financial maybe it's a risk of time
maybe it's a risk at your job maybe it's
a risk of looking bad maybe it's a risk
of failing of falling on your face of
going broke of going through pain of
going through anxiety maybe it's even a
risk in a relationship that's just going
to be difficult while you do this what
are you willing to risk
in order to win
and you have to accept that because
remember what i'm going to tell you the
price you will pay for not making your
dream come true
is far greater than the one that you
will pay to make it come true
want me to say it again the price you
will pay the suffering you will go
through to make your dream come true is
incredibly small infinitely smaller than
the price you will pay if you never do
you'll pay that one the rest of your
life and so ask yourself what you're
willing to risk what's the price you're
willing to pay i've never said this on a
show before
but a thought occurred to me when you
were talking because you remind me of
other people who have said this you
deeply love your children and i think
everybody listening to this does you
know what if you just erased everything
today you guys every show you've
listened to the most successful people i
know and by the way you're the first
person to make me have the thought just
because i feel how much you love these
two children ears
they harness love more
they harness the emotion of love they
almost leverage love yeah to go do
something great because if if love is
the most powerful emotion in the world
right if that's what it is you have to
harness that and leverage it to go do
something extraordinary because that's
the the overriding thing in this man's
mind and heart all the time all the time
when he leaves here and he's driving to
san diego with lisa right when we're in
the middle of the interview for a moment
right all your parents relate to this
when he was driving over this morning
one of the first things he thought about
this morning before he went to bed last
night
was brody and brianna
so but some of you don't harness that
it's almost like you love them and then
you set them aside when it's time for
business right don't do that harness
that power of that love right it gives
you strength and confidence so thank you
so much for sharing that man yeah in
business you can become a lot happier
person if you begin to listen less to
what people tell you they're going to do
and focus much more
intently on what they actually do
it's interesting you have friends all
your life and then you go through it
event like this you learn who your real
friends are any of you ever been through
a trial in your life for a difficult
time in my case it was a health issue
recently
um it's during those times
when people actually physically step up
and show you that they're your friend
um that you learn the most about them
it's not someone telling you i love you
or hey buddy you know care about you
it's when you need them are they there
it's what they do
friendship is an action it's an active
thing it's not a state of being
and and i learned a lot this last
month or so about uh you know some folks
frankly surprised me that reached out
and were there for me and maybe people i
didn't even know would be that don't
always verbalize it but physically
they're friends and then there's other
people that you know you've probably had
this happen too that you go through an
event and uh
you're surprised by those that don't
that weren't there that didn't call that
didn't seem to care and so you learn a
lot by what people do i've learned who
my real friends are
uh the last few weeks it's been a great
experience i have more friends than i
thought i had which is a good thing but
there were a few folks who i thought
were my friends and maybe they're not
they certainly didn't act like friends
so but how's that relate to business
well you know you get let down an awful
lot by people by listening to them you
know i've been training people now for
20 something years and well i'll tell
you people talk a good game people tell
you hey this is my time i'm gonna get
five of these this month or i'm going to
write 10 of those regardless of the
business you're in if you're training or
leading people in any way or you're on a
sales organization or if you're part of
our organization people talk constantly
and if you're if you're not careful you
begin to actually listen to them you
begin to actually believe what people
tell you they're going to do or how they
actually feel
all you've got to really do is watch
what they do
um what you do speak so loudly i can't
hear words you're saying
and you need to embody that yourself in
business because
you start to do you start to act
differently based on what people tell
you if someone tells you hey i'm feeling
great i'm going to do big things maybe
you don't do as much yourself or maybe
you don't go get that next recruit or
maybe you don't go get right that extra
sale or fight for that extra hitch
because of what other people have told
you they're going to do
and furthermore sometimes even leading
people don't listen so much to what they
do people are going to tell you what you
want to hear people tell you i feel
great things are good well the truth is
what did they do last month how much
money do they make how much business do
they write because that's really going
to indicate whether they're going to be
with you long term or not i mean if
someone's not making money if they're
not recruiting people if they're not
writing a lot of business they're on
their way out the door not on their way
stay no matter what they tell you i'm in
for life i'm committed you can depend on
me the bottom line is what did they do
last month how much money did they
really make what did they really save
are they actually behind on their bills
are they current on things and so pay
more attention to what people do
than what they say and you will have a
much better barometer of what's really
going on in your business as cool as you
might think my life is i have a
recurring nightmare that i've had for
26 years
i'm somehow walking outside a stadium
a baseball stadium
and i can hear them announcing the
starting lineup to a baseball game
i'm not kidding you and i can hear the
music playing and they say
leading off in center field number eight
and i know it's me
i played center field here and i let off
right number eight
eddie mylett and i hear him yelling
but i can't get in the stadium
i'm like i'm supposed to be playing
right like i'm supposed to be and i
cannot get in the door like i'm running
around saying look i'm the pl i'm in my
uniform i'm i'm in i'm in they're like
we don't know who you are man i'm like
no you need to let me in i just they
just announced me i'm the starting
center fielder man they're like i'm
sorry man we don't know who you are you
can't play
and then every single time i have a
dream i lap around the stadium
trying to get back in
to the game
except i can't get in
this is a true story i'm 47 years old i
had this dream last month i had it the
month before that i had it the month
before that okay
and then i wake up it's a nightmare
every time i'm in the dream i know i'm
having it but i can't get out of it
and the reason i have that dream is
because i miss playing so much
and the real reason i have the dream is
because when i was here listen to me
okay when i was here
i did not give it everything i had
over and over and over again you must be
working on how great you think you are
what you're worthy of what you deserve
because you get out the way you change
your identity
is this
you change your identity listen to me on
this remember this when i leave you
change your identity
because it's based on what you believe
you're worth
what you believe you deserve
we take it more seriously we have more
fun we're laughing our asses off but we
are out working everybody in the
conference everybody in the country we
hit the gym that way we stretch that way
you become a team nobody wants to play
now if you did that
you know what starts to happen to this
team you start to believe you deserve
stuff you probably aren't good enough to
get
you will literally win games you're not
supposed to win
this team outworks everybody in their
at-bat they battle on every pitch when
they're in the back i want you to think
about that for a minute i mean what if
you didn't give away a single freaking
pitch all year batting now one dude you
grind every pitch you battle every pitch
what if someone would have told me this
when i was here
battle every pitch man
every pitch is a fight every pitch is a
battle it's you it's a team but it's you
and the dude with the wrong lid on on
the mound battle his ass hard work
matters why is hard work matter hard
work matters strategically because if
you make more phone calls you do the old
adage right show up earlier than
everybody else leave later but there's
something more deep about that yes
making more phone calls seeing more
people being more active being busier
putting in more hours into something
always gives you a strategic chance to
be more successful it's because you've
increased your odds you've talked to
more people you're more likely to get
more prospects you're more likely to get
more clients or recruits or candidates
for your business so yes strategically
that increases your chances but
something powerful happens when you do
things other people aren't willing to do
you begin to believe you deserve to have
things other people won't have
and that's what gets you a seat at the
table of success now once you're there
it's a dog fight it's a dogfight of
skills and talents and luck and faith
and circumstance and blessing and all
that stuff but the just to get to the
table to get into the room you have to
believe you deserve to be there and so
again i want to say this to you
the hard work part plays into shifting
your identity that over time not even
that long a period of time when you're
doing the things others are unwilling to
do
you begin quietly to begin to believe
that oh i deserve to be rewarded in ways
these other people aren't going to be
rewarded because i'm doing the things
others won't do
and so the fastest way to change your
identity to change our belief is just a
flat get to work to flat get there
earlier to flat leave later to just make
more calls see more people be more
relentless just pour ourselves into the
work because actually the hard work can
in reverse impact our identity and
that's what begins to happen when you
start to do those things they won't do
you begin quietly to change your belief
that you begin to believe oh i deserve
to sit at the table with these other
people who do the things other people
aren't willing to do one of the great
distractions of chasing our dreams is
this thing that goes off in our head as
we're negotiating the price we're paying
should i keep paying it is it getting
too high is it too much and you'll have
people in your ear it's too big a
sacrifice you're going through too much
and you begin to negotiate it in your
mind it distracts all your focus you
can't be executing and negotiating
simultaneously if you're in your head
negotiating and negotiating and
negotiating you can't execute so
negotiate it now
negotiate it with me now what are you
willing to pay for me when i'm after
something big as long as it's legal
ethical and moral i'll sacrifice
everything else but i will not sacrifice
anything legal anything unethical or
anything immoral but beyond that i'm
gonna get it and i know that negotiation
comes up front i accept the suffering i
accept the sacrifice i know the
sacrifice is far smaller than the one
i'll pay if i don't do it and i
eliminate distractions and i go freaking
get what i want in my life just like you
can and this needs to be your recipe as
well if you're one of these people who's
still negotiating whether it's worth it
maybe you've got someone in your head
making you question it that is a poverty
and scarcity mentality let me prove it
to you when i didn't have money and i
spent most of my life with none
just like you what do we do when we go
into a store we don't go get what we
want we go get what we think we can
afford and so i spent the majority of my
life flipping price tags over i didn't
buy the shirt i wanted i buy the one
that i could afford
i bought things based on price not worth
and so i'm sure you i didn't buy the car
i wanted i bought the car i could afford
so when i was broke and i had scarcity
what do you do when you're in that
position you negotiate price you flip
price tags what's the cost what's the
cost what's the cost what's it cost not
what do you want
when i was poor everywhere i went flip
the price tag what's the cost what's the
cost what's the cost what's the cost i
was constantly negotiating the price for
everything in my life you do that when
you come from a place of scarcity of
being poor
successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worth
is this worth it
if you're constantly looking at the
price tag you'll eventually relent
you'll eventually give in stop
negotiating the price it's a freeing
experience to totally commit when you
totally commit to a relationship to a
business to your fitness to your faith
it's a freeing powerful it's almost like
removing kryptonite from your life when
you totally commit can you do that the
people around you it's costing too much
it's costing too much and you're going
maybe it's costing too much you gotta
start going no it's worth it
it's not the price it's the worth it's a
subtle distinction in your life that
same scarcity mentality we do in going
after our dreams we want to acquire our
dream you can't be in price tag mode
what's it cost what's it cost what's the
cost you never get what you want decide
in advance what it's going to cost and
then decide here's the subtle
distinction successful people don't
negotiate the cost of something they
negotiate whether it's worth it
that's subtle it's very subtle if you're
a person who's always thinking about
what it's costing you in the sacrifice
towards your dream you're always going
to be negotiating it but if you can
decide in advance that the cost is worth
it the negotiation stops and you go
execute what i'm telling you is if you
really want something bad enough it's
worth it it's worth it so start to feed
yourself the worth question over and
over and over again not the cost
question cost is a distraction worth is
a focus mechanism this is so worth it
it's so worth it it's so worth it focus
is you cost distracts you i found with
the people i just want you all know what
are some of the little secrets that
successful people have that they might
not even be aware of the people i've
really connected with when i've done the
show
they have massive reasons their reasons
are emotional to them they're not just
like big like i want a beach house and a
big ocean
usually the biggest reasons are other
people
the thing that will just never leave
your spirit or your heart is who you
want to be to show up in your life for
other people ask yourself this question
honestly in whatever business you're in
have you done everything physically and
mentally possible to get yourself to
that table if you've done everything
you're capable of you've been relentless
and ferocious and invested so much time
effort and energy that inside you
you know
you deserve to win or if you held
something in reserve have you not really
given it your best if you kind of hoped
you'd get a little bit luckier maybe
you've stuck your toe in or maybe you've
given most of your heart to it but not
completely all your heart and all your
effort and all your labor and all your
energy because you want to have an
excuse if it doesn't work
or maybe you want to hold a little
reserve so you don't get your hopes up
too much in case it doesn't work out
well it's that little bit of reserve you
hold back
that will ultimately keep you from
sitting at the table of success to get
to that table to sit up at the big boy
and the big lady table you're gonna have
to be giving it everything you've got so
that inside there's a shift that takes
place it says ah
i deserve this i believe i deserve to
have whatever these things are i want to
have so ask yourself that question when
this video goes away have you given it
everything and if you haven't you've got
a chance today to change that and
ultimately 30 days now completely change
what you believe you deserve and you're
a whole new person with a whole new
identity with a whole new set of beliefs
i think all successful people on some
level and to the extent you are
successful is the extent you have this
thing which is that you're willing to
step into spaces you are ill prepared
for so it seems to me like you're
willing to you kind of think like if i
get my foot in the door
then i'll figure this stuff out right
whereas what most people do this is
killing you by the way i won't step into
the door until i'm completely prepared
which is a total fallacy anyways as an
entrepreneur right for sure or wanting
to become a rapper or have a music
career or an artist or anything great if
you're waiting for a threshold of i need
to be totally prepared then i'll step in
the door you will be on the other side
of the door the rest of your life for
those of you that want to build more
confidence in your life you want to
become a super confident person
it's very simple
self-confident people do the things they
say they're going to do
over and over and over again to the
point where they keep promises they make
to themselves and they build confidence
the biggest way to build confidence in
yourself is to say you're going to do
something and then go do it whatever it
is i'm going to go prospecting and you
do it it's not even necessarily always
just a sailor just a recruit or just
something big it's even the little
things i'm going to get up earlier i'm
going to get up at 5 30. i'm going to be
in the gym at a certain time i'm going
to be at the office at a certain time
and then you do it i'm going to write
two sales and then you do it i'm going
to get a recruit and then you do it that
starts to build the muscle of confidence
in you is actually doing what you say
the rarest
human being walking the planet is
somebody who actually does what they say
they're gonna do when you get a new
person into your organization they say
i'm on fire i know these people i'm
gonna do this this or that watch what
they do if they actually go do five six
seven field training appointments the
first week if they get three four five
people to the meeting now you've got a
great new recruit if they actually go do
those things now you've got a new person
that could do something not based on
what they say begin to listen far less
to what people tell you they're going to
do
or what they're thinking and feeling and
watch them watch how they behave watch
what they do and for you to become a
leader for you to become a champion for
you to become world class at whatever it
is you're involved with
i'll submit to you that if you're a
person who does what you say you're
going to do you are the rarest of all
humans walking the earth you're in the
one percent if you actually do what you
say you're gonna do and you have
confidence when you do that if you're
someone watching this you say you know
what i've not consistently done what i
said i was gonna do you need to operate
out of your imagination not your memory
you're not your memory you're not who
you used to be you're not your past
operate out of your imagination operate
out of your vision not your memory
people operate out of their memory often
just repeat the same cycle in their life
over and over and over again people
operate out of their imagination people
who operate out of their vision move to
a new place and so if you've been
somebody who's not always done what you
said you were going to do that's that's
a memory that's in the distance we need
to focus on that we need to focus on our
vision and begin to build the habit of
moving towards and becoming the person
we want to be and the person we really
want to be
is somebody who does what they say
they're going to do someone who's a real
friend who delivers as a friend someone
if you're in love with somebody that you
you act and do and treat them like
you're in love with them someone that's
in business who does and acts and
behaves and performs and produces like
the way they say they're going to do and
when you begin to do that then you're a
real teammate when i know i can rely
when so-and-so's they're gonna do five
they do it every time it's in the bank
and when you're that reliable you have
self-confidence and then i build
confidence in you i have confidence in
you if you are a part of my business or
my team you earn my confidence you earn
my trust you earn my respect and you
earn it by doing what you say you're
gonna do you're in my friendship that
way
you earn your stripes in business that
way and you earn your confidence that
way there's also this misconception from
people
that you are certain things meaning some
people have this misconception that i am
what i possess
in other words i am my possessions and
so they link their self-confidence to
their possessions and so they're
constantly trying to acquire more and
more possessions thinking that's where
they get their self-confidence from
that's how they're defined as a person i
am my possessions
couldn't be further from the truth it's
a hollow way to try to gain
self-confidence by possessing things
nothing wrong with going for material
possessions i have all kinds of them but
i don't link my confidence to those
possessions nor am i deluded into
thinking if i could just possess more
things then i'll feel better about
myself so this is a mistake there's a
flawed thought number one flawed thought
i am my possessions second flawed
thought i am my accomplishments in other
words my self-confidence is only linked
to what i accomplish so because i
haven't accomplished certain things i
don't have that certain title that
certain award that certain recognition i
don't believe in myself i'm riddled with
self-doubt i'm defined by my
accomplishments the difficult thing
about that is now all your life you're
gonna have to accomplish more and more
and more in order to feel self-confident
and eliminate self-doubt you are not
your accomplishments you are not your
possessions you are you you are perfect
you are beautiful you were born to do
something great with your life if you're
a person of faith like me you believe
god made you in his image and likeness
and wants you to do something great with
your life not that you are your
possessions not that you are your
accomplishments and this is the social
media insidious influence it has in our
lives people think i don't feel good
about myself i've got this self-doubt
the gateway to me feeling more
self-confidence is if i could possess
more things or if i could accomplish
more things yes having nice things will
make you feel better about yourself yes
accomplishing things certainly is a
reinforcement for self-confidence but
it's not the pathway to getting it the
pathway to getting it is doing something
great with your life where you keep the
promises you make to yourself and
acknowledge
this self-doubt this self-thought this
negative talk isn't even mine it was
given to me when it was impossible for
me to defend myself as a child and maybe
it even happened in adolescence and
probably some of those incidences have
happened for you as an adult
and these ones as an adult are like that
thing i said earlier oh it's another
time i reinforced the table i'm not good
enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
prepared enough i'm not the right race
i'm not the right gender i don't come
from the right kind of family i don't
have the right education and we find
these references as adults to reinforce
these self-doubting beliefs we were
given by somebody else as a child flawed
belief is that you are your possessions
you are your accomplishments third
flawed belief
i am what other people say i am
wrong you are not what other people say
you are good or bad i see too many
people that if someone says something
negative about them they believe that's
who they are this is the flawed third
belief i am my possessions i am my
accomplishments and you know what or i
am what other people say i am let me be
clear with you you are not what other
people tell you you are it wasn't true
when you were 18 months old 5 years old
or 55 years old you are not what other
people say you are so stop letting that
dictate your self-confidence or fill you
with self-doubt and for the record you
are also not the good things people tell
you you are all the time don't live for
likes don't live for comments on your
social media don't don't do things in
your life just to solicit
someone saying something great about you
it's a cheap shallow
hollow way to try to gain self-esteem
and self-confidence it's fleeting it's
short-term and it's needy in fact the
fact that it is a necessity for you to
get liked to get people to say good
things to get comments on your social
media or to do so in your presence
indicates a lack of self-esteem and
self-confidence because we know
self-confidence is an internal game
where we keep the promises we make to
ourselves
the fourth type of flawed thinking is i
am what i look like
in other words if i don't look a certain
way like what the magazine says i should
or social media says i should if i don't
look like these people i shouldn't have
self-confidence and that's ridiculous i
can tell you straightforwardly you're
beautiful as you are especially the
ladies listening to this are watching
this the world is constantly trying to
get you to believe you're not enough you
don't look right you should lose this
weight you should gain this this should
be smaller that should be bigger
whatever it might be they're constantly
messaging women you're not enough you're
not enough you're not enough you are
what you look like and this is true for
men as well let me tell you straight
forward that you are not what you look
like you are your soul you are your
spirit you are your gifts
you are the contributions you make you
are your intentions at some point you
got to stop negotiating the price and
decide your will to win is not for sale
here's the truth
most people's dreams can be bought
with enough failure with enough
rejection they will sell their
children's dreams they can't still fight
they'll take they can get a little bit
but when it gets a little too hot
they'll boom sold buy the dream you can
have it it's not worth it to me and
their will to win is viable you can buy
it with a little success or a whole
bunch of failure most people will sell
their will to win some of you have sold
it because you're making a little bit of
money you don't work like you did when
you were making nothing you're not after
it like when you were broke now you got
your 50 100 200 300 400 measly dollars a
year
million bucks a year not to be rude but
i would not pay my jet fuel
and you think you're making a lot of
money compared to what
but you sold your win for a little
couple success
some of you will sell your win for some
failure you're probably viable but if
you decide at this meeting my will
cannot be bought i don't care how long
it takes you can't buy this dude out
i'll keep fighting for my family i'm the
one i'm gonna change my family tree
forever
that's the decision decide now you're
gonna keep negotiating the price or can
you not be bought what are you doing to
intentionally create bliss
in the lives of the people that you care
about because this is the pathway to
getting more of it ourselves the more we
begin to give other people bliss the
more we begin to consciously make
choices that give bliss to other people
in their lives the more we begin to
experience an abundance ourselves so
what are you doing to help other people
win other people contribute other people
get significance and recognition other
people have more peace and ecstasy and
joy and passion in their lives because
once you begin to create it for other
people when you're intentional about it
you'll have more of it yourself these
are the patterns that i'd like to see
kick in for you that when they kick in
you begin to run a pattern in a program
that leads you to bliss leads you to a
win leads you to increase and also leads
to it with someone in your life that if
you do have a conflict with somebody
that you run a pattern that eventually
leads maybe it's understanding them
maybe it's confronting them maybe it's
talking about it it's not always when
you're in a disagreement that you lead
to a win that you must win this that you
must overcome the fact that they think
this of you what if you were consciously
choosing every time you got into a
disagreement with your spouse this will
eventually lead to more bliss at least
that was your outcome now the steps you
take it's probably going to be ugly in
the beginning you're probably gonna have
to some understanding you may not even
agree on everything but if your
intention is that it leads to bliss
rather than you winning rather than you
controlling them rather than you making
it go away rather than you running a
pattern if when you're beginning to
succeed in business if your outcome is
more bliss more winning you'll run a
pattern that does more of that you know
what you allow is what's going to
continue in your life i put out a post
about this several weeks ago
it's hard to accept this but what's
happening in our lives we're allowing it
to happen and to some extent we almost
believe we deserve it because we produce
in our life what we really believe we're
worth what we really believe we deserve
and it doesn't it's hard to accept that
because it seems coincidental you know
that the wrong person or a life or there
was a business setback or our car broke
down or you know our company went out of
business or whatever it might be one of
your clients just quit and change their
mind and it seems coincidental but you
really truly are getting out of your
life when you believe you're worth what
you believe you deserve and you're
allowing it to happen and i'm going to
challenge you today to stop that stop
allowing it and know that you deserve
better great businesses those of you
that are business people great
businesses have a cult-like following
have a religious-like following it's
something that all great movements have
apple has it the great fitness companies
that you think of any company you know
that's really flourishing has kind of
raving fans and a level past that is
almost cult-like and religious like
followers they believe that deeply and
by the way i don't mean that in a
sacrilegious way like they believe in it
more than they believe in god you know
exactly what i mean when i say that deep
raving fans and those followings are led
by evangelists all great business people
i think all great dads all great moms
should be evangelical about their family
all great business leaders should be
evangelists constantly touting the
greatness of your family the greatness
of where you're going the greatness of
your company most people don't
understand you can obliterate most
problems with just massive action i see
people hem and haw and make excuses all
the time when challenges arise and it
would have just been solved if you'd
decided you'd have been totally certain
and you'd obliterate that problem with
some massive action here's where the two
things were this morning was very
unusual number one was the water was
unusually cold this morning uh really
cold and the waves were huge very big
waves this morning and both of those
things made me think about business and
there's an application for you that i
wanted to share with you the first one
was just getting into the water this
morning
it was freezing
and when i had to get in there to make a
decision how do i get in do i kind of
take my time where i go my feet in first
kind of get adapt and then come out get
adapted go back in up to my waist get a
little warmer then come back in up to my
neck you get the deal
but all that would do is extend the pain
all that does it's logical it makes
sense
don't go until you're ready take your
time but really all that does what does
that really do that extends the pain and
so i didn't do that i did what the pros
do right which is what people do in
every endeavor that are champions is i
ran boom right in headlong right into
the water right you dive in there's a
shock
but then you get adapted so much more
quickly than you could possibly imagine
and then you're off to ride in the waves
well the same is true in business the
champions and everything i don't care if
it's your fitness if it's your your
family your faith you name it the way
that you get great at something as you
dive into it and get adapted quickly and
you'll be surprised at your ability to
adapt and navigate your way through
success the average people and
everything frankly the people who lose
are the ones who constantly take their
time they're too logical they think well
i can't do this until i'm ready if i'm
not ready i'll mess it up and i don't
want to get it's too cold it's too it's
too freezing
well the truth is in business that's not
how it works if you go slow you're
extending the time you're in pain and
worse yet
while the champions have already dove in
got acclimated they're out there riding
their waves making progress you're still
on the shore deciding whether you're
going to get ready to get ready
so if you're an entrepreneur if you're a
business owner you're somebody getting
associated with my firm which is a
wonderful decision by the way but if
you're going to decide that
you've got to decide that and go and
trust the fact that you have your
instincts your background your training
your mentors the system around you and
that's true whether you're an
entrepreneur in my business or you're
one of these firms that i've spoken to
on the outside i want to encourage all
of you if you're going to get in get
into business and go you'll be amazed at
your capacity to evolve and to adapt and
to succeed one of the things we have to
do to create a new identity is to begin
to tell a new story what's your new
story who are you now
what are you all about now where are you
going now
what's this new version of you see
here's what's amazing at any point in
your life you can just decide to write a
new script you can decide to become a
whole new character see the leading
character in the story of your life is
you
and guess what you and god control the
script you can write a new script at any
time you want listen to me at any time
you want you can simply decide to be a
new character i'm strong now i'm
beautiful now i'm handsome now i'm bold
now i'm funny now i'm smart now i'm
going there now
stop telling the old story here's the
truth nobody cares no one cares if you
had a failure
no one cares if you've had a setback no
one cares if you had a victory and none
of those failures none of those setbacks
none of those victories and that old
character you keep playing is the very
thing that will prevent you from
becoming this new version of you
it's a story if you're stuck it's an old
story you're telling with an old
character that was last year's version
last decade's version who's the new
character what's the new script what's
the new story life is messy by the way
so is business
so is a happy life in fact remember this
the messier your life is probably the
happier you are the most out of control
you've ever been in your life here's my
bet you were the happiest because when
you're in college cramming for finals or
when you were chasing something in your
life at any time and it was out of
control one of the great fallacies of
life a total load of bs is the concept
of balance balance is bs you're never
gonna have total balance in your life
and you don't want it balance is boredom
every area of your life it's sometimes
gonna be peaking or priming compared to
another one and you don't want that
remember this the amount of uncertainty
you can handle at any given time is
directly related to how happy and
productive and fulfilled you're going to
be so embrace the mess great
entrepreneurs they create messes
everywhere it's your addiction to
thinking you're in control that's
holding you back in your business your
relationships and your life you're not
in control you're never going to be
embrace the mess and you'll max it out
some of you done so much work to get out
there to finally catch the wave anybody
ever caught a wave in business
or a wave in the ocean for that matter
you cut your wave in the ocean you know
what that's like a perfect wave or a
good wave all of you probably done at
least a little one and
it's almost inexpressible isn't it it's
an incredible feeling you're kind of
connected to god and the ocean and
yourself in those moments and it's just
a wonderful journey and these waves can
take you places you would ever otherwise
never get without them and you can get
there faster also true in business you
gotta paddle and kick and scratch and
claw and move and you're using things
you've never used before you're finding
assets you have that you didn't even
know you had to get out there then you
catch these waves in business and it's
wonderful and it can take you places and
it feels a certain way it's never felt
before
and many of you caught waves i'm sure
you've caught a wave in business in the
past or multiple waves some of you
probably got some pretty darn big ones
but let me ask you a question
what if when i got out there i started
to say to myself well you know heck i've
caught three or four of these waves this
is pretty darn good
i could probably float
and i'll probably just keep catching
them if i float but would i
well you know i wouldn't what would
happen if i stopped completely moving my
arms and legs
and kicking and paddling
i'd sink
and if i'm not careful if i don't do it
long enough i could drown and i see that
happen all the time in business see in
my business the paddling and the kicking
and the swimming is recruiting and
developing people leadership sales
skills running a system in a particular
way those are the things that are the
paddling and the kicking and prospecting
in my business in your business it may
be something different but nonetheless
i'm not immune to the laws of nature if
i sit in that ocean and i stop moving i
stop paddling and kicking and doing what
you got to do i won't float i'll sink
i'm not immune to the laws of the ocean
nature the universe gravity you name it
and neither are you i'm also not immune
and nor are you to the laws of business
the laws of success the laws of success
say if you stop doing those things you
don't float you never grow or you never
just stay the same in business you're
either growing or dying you're either
sinking or swimming i want you to be
swimming i want you to be riding waves
by the way the bigger the waves the
harder you got to work to go catch them
but what most people do in business is
they fall in love with the delusion or
the illusion of the fact that i can stop
at some point i've seen people stop
quickly in my business a couple weeks
into the business they get an award for
bringing the most people to the meeting
oh i can stop kicking and paddling now i
can stop calling people and seeing
people and i see them sink i've seen
people a year or two later get a
promotion to a certain level and they go
oh now i can stop paddling and kicking
and i'm going to float and keep riding
these waves and i've seen them sink
and sometimes i've seen them drowned
and that's a sad thing to see someone
drowned and go out of business just
simply because they fell in love with
the illusion and the lie
that they can float and stop moving i've
seen it happen five years in 15 years in
20 years in a million year 2 million a
year you name it i've seen them when
they've developed a bunch of people when
they haven't
you'd say well yeah that's not true i
mean not everybody sinks i mean i have
friends heck in my own business who
they've stopped paddling kicking and
they still ride a wave or two here and
there and they're pretty happy
really
are they really happy will they ever
know what it would have been like to
ride the biggest and best waves of their
life the answer is no if you stop
paddling kicking you'll never know where
you could have gone
more importantly you'll never know who
you could have become
see the people who paddle and kick
forever and make that decision they've
got a chance to become the highest
version of themselves the highest
expression of themselves which i think
is what life's about see the champions
in fitness in faith in the water in
every area of life make a decision early
that they are about the paddling and
kicking because that's the ticket to the
biggest the next and the biggest waves
of life
life isn't about catching a few and
stopping life's about the next wave ask
any surfer they're chasing the next big
wave they're chasing the great one and
once they catch that they want to chase
another one because it's about being out
there it's about being in the game it's
about riding the big waves it's about
finding the highest version and
expression of you
and i want to challenge you to do that
in your business i want to challenge you
see the great ones decide see the
average
they they look for reasons
they look for reasons to stop paddling
kicking oh now i can oh now i can
see the champions don't want those
reasons the champions want to keep
paddling and kicking to ride the big one
the great wave of their life
and i think you'd agree with me that
life can only get better if you'll keep
paddling and kicking please don't stop
please don't fall in love with that lie
and know the truth that the winning way
is the way to keep paddling and kicking
you're not about floating you're not
about sinking you're not about drowning
you're about riding the biggest waves of
your life in the future and whatever
area matters to you whether it's your
faith or your family or your fitness or
your business make the decision that
you're going to do the things that's
required to ride the next big wave and
it will take you places you can't even
imagine it's not the success of people
you know that's making you unhappy it's
your comparing your situation to the
success they're having that creates
unhappiness in your life so for those of
you that are struggling and saying you
know one of the things i suffer from is
i'm just not very happy very often i can
tell you that that presence
of unhappiness you will always link to a
comparison of some sort either in your
own life or in other people's lives and
just being aware of that fact and
stopping the comparison embracing this
moment embracing this time knowing that
you can't go back to that previous time
knowing that you can't be in somebody
else's life you're not gonna have that
other body right now and so if you're
looking to be happier i can promise you
the number one key that i would give you
is to stop the comparison game you'd say
well that's not completely true i mean
what if someone passes away that makes
me unhappy there's no comparison there
let's take the most extreme example
or when someone's sick in my family uh
you know someone in my family's got a
really bad illness that makes me unhappy
that's not a comparison in fact it is
the fact of the matter is that when
someone gets sick in your family or
passes away what you do in your mind is
you compare it to when they were healthy
so that comparison of i wish they were
healthier again that is a comparison
between the previous situation and the
current condition if someone passes away
it's comparing the time that you had
them that's why people say if i could
just have one more moment with them if i
could just have another conversation
it's comparing it to when you had the
moment it's comparing it to when you had
the conversation and so those are
extreme examples
but if we reduce it all the way down to
anything right now in your life that you
say it brings me unhappiness there's no
joy there there's a comparison happening
that's not serving you when i'm having a
difficult time in my life in one area
another all i have to really do is look
back 60 to 90 days and it's the
behaviors i had 60 to 90 days ago that
are causing the results i get negatively
right now and so like for example when
i'm not really you know progressing in
my career or in my financial situation
if i look back 60 to 90 days prior i
stopped reading the books listening to
the audios doing the things that grow my
identity and i pay the price 60 to 90
days later in my body my body isn't
looking like i want it to if i look back
60 to 90 120 days that's when my diet
got weaker that's when my workouts
weren't quite as intense as they were
previously and i pay the price three to
four months later
this is true in every area of our life
our lives are almost like reading a
newspaper today
but we're reading the headlines from 90
days ago and so that's what confuses
people they see the external results of
their life but but if you did if you
read the newspaper from 90 to 120 days
ago that's where the news was made not
today and so in every area of your life
you got it going right now you got to
fuel the fire if you've got your
business going your finances going your
relationship going your faith going
where you want it to you have to
continue to do the activities that got
you here in the first place because 90
days from now you're going to read
today's news
that's how it works if you meet people
that you think are egomaniacs that are
consciously bragging about themselves
these are the most insecure people that
you know they're the most fearful people
that you know they're the most scared
and they're usually the least happy and
so but i'm going to say something to you
i want you to consider as i go through
ego today i know you think wow i'm so
down on myself how could i have an ego
it's actually the people that are down
on themselves that actually have their
ego materialize and show up more often
than they think and it's their ego that
may actually be holding them back you
think wow how could someone with low
self-esteem have a big ego
trust me they do and so egos are not
part of people with high self-esteem the
people in my life that are the most
self-confident
typically don't have big egos if you
have to wait around for other people to
tell you hey your ego's out of control
it's too late usually so we've got to be
able to see our ego when it rears its
head be aware of it and it loses its
power over us we can go back to being
our real selves you can't love yourself
if you're not being yourself
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself but remember this when
ego shows up we're not ourselves we're
not connected to god in other words if
you can let go of your ego you can let
god in we can let go of your ego you can
let your real confidence in when you let
go of your ego you can go really become
who you were born to be and so
oftentimes this is so
important you get
you may be losing right now because of
your ego
because of your ego because you're not
feeling good about yourself beliefs are
so important to guard
because once you have a belief your
brain goes to work i've said this in
another audio video where your brain has
to go to work to prove your beliefs to
be true your brain literally goes to
work on finding the evidence to prove
you right and so that identity you're
constantly reinforcing it let me give
you an example of what i mean if you
believe a certain worth about yourself a
certain identity that impacts the type
of action you're willing to take so if
there's a goal you've got set it doesn't
matter what it is pick a goal
to the extent that you believe it's
consistent with your identity
is to the extent that you will make an
effort towards it
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy however
because what happens is if your identity
is here and the goal is there you will
only make an effort congruent with what
you believe you're worth and so that
limited effort you make
produces the result not consistent and
it reinforces the belief it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy so you set a
goal that is inconsistent with an
identity you're working on you will only
make an effort consistent with the
identity which will get you to hear
doesn't produce the result and it
reinforces this belief you have about
yourself so it's important as you set
new goals as you set new visions that
you also upgrade your identity
simultaneously you're in process of
upgrading it because that identity
impacts the effort you make right
impacts the will you put towards it and
that will is reinforced by the lack of
result and so it becomes this
self-fulfilling prophecy see your mind
has this belief it wants to prove to be
true and it starts to find references so
if you believe you're 75 degrees it's
going to start finding legs to put under
that table to make it immobile so it
can't move to prove you right and so our
identity equals our effort and the
challenge is that effort produces the
result and so this identity has
everything to do with the efforts you
make which produces the result which
will reinforce the identity or the lack
thereof
so it's critical that you upgrade
identity with your new visions and goals
i don't think i don't really believe in
this mentor stuff
i don't know that i buy into that like
like i don't think i influence you by
you necessarily asking me questions and
i answer them don't you find that too
like almost sometimes people that want
you to mentor them they're almost
interviewing you and i think that's
almost like a school teacher so if you
look at your kids
the people that influence them their
teachers influence them to a degree
that's like a mentor right because they
shape them and
there's influence there but who do you
really worry about you worry about who
their friends are because they're
friends you show me their friends i'll
pretty much tell you who's influencing
them so i think what i do a decent job
is when i do get to know these folks i
don't treat them like they're some god
figure or they're any different than me
or anything i mean i treat them like a
friend right right and i want to make
them talk about people that maybe have
achieved something in a space above you
they're constantly donovan was on your
program earlier he'll tell you people
constantly when you're in that
environment treat you as if you're
different than them or better than them
they use a million people like that
they're not any better than you they
often have a blessing and a skill or a
set of facts and knowledge that's ahead
of you right right so make them your
friend that's how like you and i we're
becoming friends the way you're gonna
influence me i'm gonna have influence
over you we're gonna have an interview
today we're gonna learn some things but
really is our friendship just
associating just being around each other
so i think probably the biggest thing is
i've made them my real friend i want you
to remember something
comparison is the pathway to unhappiness
i'm telling you that in every area of
your life where you find unhappiness you
will find comparison in fact the
antithesis to that is also true
when there is no comparison
you cannot create unhappiness in your
life that's a pretty bold and powerful
statement but it's true we only feel
unhappy in our lives when we compare
something to maybe something in our life
that was a different time maybe perhaps
when we were wealthier or in a different
relationship or we were healthier on
some level comparing our current
conditions to previous ones that
comparison is what creates the
unhappiness that's actually not the
condition itself or perhaps you're in a
relationship where you compare it to a
previous relationship you had and how
they treated or how you felt at that
time perhaps you compare this time in
your life just to a simply a different
time and that comparison will always
create unhappiness in your life if you
can remove yourself from comparing both
yourself to a previous time in your life
a previous condition a previous
situation or even comparing yourself to
other people
in your life this is a recipe and a
formula for unhappiness every single
time in your life where you're
experiencing unhappiness you are doing a
comparison to something it's the
contradiction between your current
situation current relationship current
body current finances current anything
and something exterior either a previous
time in your life a previous person in
your life or you comparing yours to
someone else's
it is
an insidious disease that so many people
in society suffer from today
particularly because of the advent of
social media we watch someone's video of
what they're doing on a friday night and
it's not what they're doing that makes
us unhappy it's comparing what they're
doing to what we're doing ask yourself
truthfully your big goals and dreams are
you really clear on what they are
because if you don't have that we can't
even get started but assuming you've
listened to all of my previous content
before you know how mandatory it is to
be clear and specific for what you want
right but then the next layer is this
can you get laser obsessively focused
almost to its exclusivity almost
but for an extended period of time
can you honestly say you've done that
for an extended period i'm talking about
a year two years three years four years
five years even a decade towards
something you want so badly you want it
like oxygen it's like you want it like
you want to eat you want it like you
want to live right well are you
extendedly laser focused on it or do you
get distracted easily
this is the global express really global
express is i guess it's the largest or
one of the two largest corporate jets
that you can really
you know buyable corporate jets that are
available and so it's owned by oracle
we're going to get on here i hope the
inside's great because if it is i'm
buying this thing
this thing is
massive
just to give you an idea
of how big this thing is
look at this
[Music]
unbelievable the interior is meticulous
it's got all the upgrades you would want
millions and millions of dollars in
upgrades track there's probably got more
in upgrades than the plane is actually
worth
and so i'm gonna pull the trigger on
this we're gonna hopefully make a deal
right now
if you're wondering whether i think 2021
is going to be a better year i do
because uh
making a bet that i'm gonna be using
this thing so anyway very very excited
about it and it's my dream dream dream
dream jet so
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible motivation from garyvee check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe see
you there it is far more fun to die on
your sword than to die on someone else's
dying on your sword is better than dying
on someone else's so many of you are
doing things making decisions and
navigating your lives based on somebody
else's thesis